[Musique]
haha
allez mais dans une chicha de banlieue
dans lequel mon petit héros enfin je
dois faire un showcase et il a été
chercher la protection du rappeur la
crime sauf que dès que la crème est
parti la violence a repris ses droits
cherchez pas la victime dans la série
c'est bien alors tu souris moi je pense
qu'on va faire travailler mon acolyte de
toujours va se faire casser la gueule
par un baiser par mon ennemi juré
carnage des pages soient plus forts
rebonds certains comédiens pour moi
c'est maquillage c'est mesure où je fais
hall et ses cascades aussi voilà ça
c'est bien ça me prend ça mais kraft
contre le havre a beau à la fin ils sont
jeunes ils sont 5 si ça va mettre des
coudes en vendant la tête et tout je
suis désolé frères des secteurs le
secteur ce qui s'est passé près
là c'est la furie total et les vallées
je suis boxeur mois donc du coup j'ai
pas de problème avec ça
après
boxer d'un vrai wibaut servat cinéma
c'est plutôt très excitant tourner des
scènes comme ça en fait
et là les garçons ils ont kiffé jouer à
100 il faut qu'on assume on parle d'un
milieu dans lequel la violence existe
c'est vrai il ya des embrouilles entre
rappeurs qui ont été extrêmement
médiatisé comme tout le monde s'est
alors là c'est violent ce film est
relayée et c
et puis toute la violence dont une grand
public et pas au courant et qui existe
de manière assez importante alors
évidemment il ya certains rappeurs qui
sont moins touchés que d'autres par ça
parce qu'ils viennent pas des mêmes
milieux qui ont pas les mêmes relations
mais enfin le rap dur c'est pas un
milieu de bisounours
donc oui à la testostérone il ya des
rivalités il ya de la jalousie et tout
ça entraîne parfois de la violence est
une réalité que qu'il fallait que je
traite quoi et puis au delà de ça qui
est plutôt cinématographique à fumer en
plus d une création originale à
découvrir en avant-première en ce moment
sur my canal